yeah you mentioned earlier that this is
like a playbook this whole
demoralization tactic basically what's
going on you build the legs so that you
can knock one out and close the system
and
and i wanted to what other situations
have you noticed this playbook
being played in terms of our society
yeah in our society all over like look
at look at how
let's start with academia okay first
thing they do
introduce the idea that kids need to see
each other is the color of their skin
instead of
their actual character okay so critical
race theory steps in then you push in
gender ideology in california
as young as first grade you're teaching
them with a gender bred man
teaching them that well you're actually
not just male or female you can be
any of these things that sound fun so
you pick
and that's something that the parent
actually has no right to opt their child
out of now in california
okay it used to be in california you
could opt out when we lived there
my son at five years old had two
children in his class
come out as trans kids okay five years
old
my son wanted to be a hot dog i told
lydia that he wanted
a hot dog then what what they're doing
is they're creating
paths of division exactly and so
everything becomes divided entirely my
older daughter in california her school
they had a guy come in and tell
everybody they have white privilege and
tell the white kids
they shouldn't sit together unless they
let it have a minority at the table
because it could make minorities feel
like they're not invited
okay again teaching the kids see each
other is different by these exterior
characteristics not internal so that's
what matters
it's going back to segregation or racism
in a whole weird different regressive
way
but all of this is built to weaken
society and then same thing with just
the messaging about family
that a family no longer is is you know
this
unit that it can be anything you can
just make up whatever you want and
that's
it is whatever it is you know you can
call yourself a dad no matter what you
are you know it doesn't matter nothing
has a real definition there's no shared
language
language is the next one we can't even
agree on language the definition of what
things mean
we were just talking about that before
the show that like there's all these
words
somebody could use without even knowing
they're using a word that offends
somebody because the language keeps
changing
they change the language intentionally
so that we can't communicate effectively
because shared languages
is the key to us having a cultural sort
of
peace amongst each other divide and
conquer yeah and
this goes across everything like look at
entertainment in entertainment here's
another thing 15 years
20 years of subtly giving impressions to
little kids
teenagers and adults where along the way
you teach them things and you do it
really subtly over the course of their
life so like i can give you an example
really recent history like the recent
scooby-doo movie
they give multiple impressions to ruth
bader ginsburg being a hero of women's
rights
then they go to talking about yeah in
scooby-doo which
then they talk the most recent one and
then they talk about tinder
in it okay and then they talk about
toxic masculinity those are the three
things they hit in that movie that are
subtle points for a kid to bring in
these impressions are in everything a
kid consumes and coming from hollywood
i'm like totally
acutely aware of all of this they do
this throughout their life and then what
happens at school
their professors their teachers who are
remarkably on the left
they reinforce those values that
entertainment is giving them
a lot of those if your family tends to
have somewhat conservative values even
if you're like a blue dog democrat
their kids then push back against those
values and think your values are
inherently wrong and there's something
wrong with them because everything i
watch
and everything in school tells me that
this is bad again
dividing families dividing our culture
and the sort of ability to have peace
amongst each other quite a bit the
opposite of
judeo-christian values you know notably
like honor their father and thy mother
exactly now it's your mom is dumb and
your parents are racist don't tell them
i told you
otherwise they'll say racist things
exactly trick you and
parents are putting their kids in these
schools like stop sending your kids to
these places
man it goes both ways too and
entertainment too and school stop giving
money to people who hate you
if they hate you don't give them your
money it's one of the biggest mistakes
people make
like you can't be a lazy person right
now you have to stand up for what you
believe in and if a company comes out
some will corporation they say
x is racist or this is bad and they come
out and they take social positions they
know nothing about
then divorce from them get a divorce
with your tv
divorce netflix whatever it is in your
life where this happens
or it's an and a university your kid
goes to same thing take them out pull
them out go to a different school
what are some examples like historically
where countries have gone through this
china china went through a color
revolution cuba went through it
venezuela went through this i mean
pretty much you can go through the
playbook of all these countries who
eventually turned to
you know left-wing dictatorships whether
they be socialists in the beginning or
communist
they all pretty much went through this
it was a cultural revolution that kicked
it off
and they hit all of those pillars of
culture entertainment
academia and um you know our news media
those are the places that they weaken
first because those control perception
and perception is reality for too many
people
it's not so much like a big mistake and
we talked about this earlier too
is that this idea that facts over
feelings is something that is going to
draw over
people who are not on your side already
is is actually kind of a broken idea
because a lot of the conditioning that's
been out there has been that
you're taught that these feelings and
movies and feelings from
all these different places that you
listen to as a child are reality
so you need to message an emotional
message that reaches people in a way
that says
hey emotionally this is how you put this
policy in context the left does that
really well we don't
there's one thing however that's very
different for the united states than any
of these other countries
we have we have gun culture it's not
just the guns because many of these
countries did have them
and then they got taken away no we have
gun culture
we have people who have tons of guns and
will say something like mola
was it lave is that you pronounce it
yeah or uh uh um
my cold dead hands so it's gonna be very
very difficult
to pull off what they pulled off and say
china where they took old people and put
them in dunce caps and then
held strung them up in the city and
started screaming and laughing at them
and mocking them until they
bent the knee and agreed to communism
because you're gonna get some old
fat trucker guy who's gonna be like i
don't care he's gonna pull out a gun and
be like get away from me it makes me
think that it's happened
historically like throughout millennia
that the founding fathers saw that and
we're like we need to enshrine a couple
of basics
so that it we can circumvent or at least
resist when this starts to happen
there were some founding fathers that
didn't want a bill of rights and there
were some that were like we don't want
the federal government have too much
power
so we need a list i think there was
originally 17 and they condensed them
got rid of some and now we had then we
had 10 and the right to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed but hey
they're infringing quite a bit aren't
they
every single day they're infringing more
and more and they're messaging
why are they messaging so hard on gun
control it's because they're fully aware
that that's the one element that's a
wild card in america versus all these
other places this has happened the more
they can clamp down on that and narrow
the culture that's why a registry is
very important too
having a registry that says exactly what
people have where they have it
that's important to them because that
would be really essential if you
actually went all the way with this
but that search for control that's the
wild card is people having guns here
and it's something i tell people all the
time is like these people who have been
overtaking these other countries and who
have died or gone to gulags
they wish they had had guns when people
came to their house don't give up your
guns whatever you do whatever you think
whatever time you think it is right now
in america don't give up your guns
hitler i think established a national
registry didn't he for the guns
he did and he also he did take guns
there was confiscation
in in jewish areas so he did the same
thing castro took guns i mean this is
this is an ongoing thing you know
and and of course they always talk about
safety right for safety
and for for the community to be more
just and
and more happy you know they go with all
the same stuff that they push now just
we do it in a lot prettier way in modern
times you know they they do flashy ads
and emotional pleas
that well this kills kids what's amazing
and i always ask people about this is
why have you never heard them talk about
handgun control when that's
the majority of the deaths from guns
come from handguns they don't start
there because they know
what a like that's that's not happening
they know that's not the first step
it's kind of what you said it's
incrementalism let's start with the gun
that looks scary even though knives and
stabbings
kill four times as many people as ar-15s
let's start there because it looks scary
so that's that's the incremental first
step
and and one of the challenges uh is that
the the gun control people are
really they're really dumb and a lot of
them are like lemmings
you know you play the game lemmings or
they just like walk and follow each
other
because you'll hear a lot of the same
things from the same people that make no
sense
they'll be like no self-respecting
hunter whatever use an assault weapon
and then the first question is like okay
first of all what does that have to do
with second amendment i thought that was
about it it didn't say yeah
it didn't say uh deer hunting being
necessary to protect a free state the
right to keeping bear shall not be
infringed instead
you know a well-regulated well-regulated
militia the right of the people to keep
and bear arms so i don't know where
hunting comes from
then they say assault weapon what is an
assault weapon there's no
in their mind it has to look scary it
looks scary
weapon yeah and you'll say like
are you talking specifically about like
a carbine with like a folding stock or
something like what is that a reference
and they'll say yeah that okay well what
is it they won't know
then they'll say but still you know no
hunter will use an assault weapon and
i'm like well based on your definition
or like say new jersey's definition
you're completely correct they're gonna
use like an ar-15
chambered in like 308 or bushmaster
which by their definition is not an
assault weapon
but it's much much more powerful you
have no idea what you're talking about
these people are insane
it's because at the end of the day it
has nothing to do with actually
preventing gun crime it has to do with
the slow incremental push to take guns
out of people's hands and it's not the
criminals they want to take the hands
out of because they're not worried about
them pushing back
they like the radical government crime
is good they love that part crime is a
destabilizing factor here what have they
done and there's another question people
should ask themselves if they're curious
you know about gun control and they
haven't really decided where they they
are is
ask yourself what was the last push
democrats made to get rid of illegal
guns
in cities in places like chicago or
baltimore or memphis when was the last
time they did that and there hasn't been
this big push to get rid of illegal guns
who are on the street
because of gangs what's an illegal gun
a gun that they stole you know a stolen
gun something somewhere
somebody else's property so okay so the
gun isn't the issue no no the gun's not
i'm saying
why are they not going after the fact
that you know these gangs they
in many cases have stash houses where
they have tons of firearms that they've
stolen
they don't try and go get those back
well that's a property crime
exactly i think they should have those
guns i think the stolen guns
well i don't think they should have
stolen property but again so there's a
difference between the property crime
and gun ownership
yeah you know they should be allowed to
have guns legally if they get caught in
a crime then you take it away but the
fact that they're stolen
and they know where these gangs are and
they don't go in and take their guns
why do they want to go abiding guns this
is just sort of a thought
practice you know an exercise for people
is like they want to take away my ar-15
but they don't want to take away this
guy's gun who stole it in a car jacket
well hold on i just think they're
they're they broadly want to take a take
away everyone's ar-15s
the problem is there's no way to stop a
criminal from getting a gun
oh no absolutely not no but that's all
that really happened
the fact they make no effort to even
stop the gang crime
with guns tells you everything about why
they they go after things like ar-15
well
it's it's questionable is a gun buyback
trying to stop it they do that um they
arrest people and charge them for having
guns i don't think they should
sometimes the only crime a person
commits is that they had a gun and i'm
like how's that a crime having a guy
that's not that's but that's a lot of
what they do
so it doesn't work yeah there's still
and chicago isn't predominantly gang
crime it's like honor crime it's like
you insulted me so i'll go and shoot up
your house
that's what people do so either way i'm
like you know
that's going back to like the abolish
the police stuff i'm like shouldn't
conservatives just be on personal
responsibility at this point
if there's no cops then there's no gun
laws i do think we should let certain
areas test it out if a city wants to
have no police they vote to have no
police then go ahead and try it knock
yourselves out you're going to find out
really fast that the police kept you
safe for a very long time
you weaken them to this point you're
going to end up with what the uk has
they'll have little batons and they'll
do nothing but come to your house to
tell you that you insulted somebody
online
this is the big difference between the
culture or factions so
uh glenn greenwald yeah he's pretty much
left right but he's not on the left
culture or whatever to call it
i'm like center left liberal but clearly
not in that faction either
and there's one really easy way to
understand it those people are morons
why they want to abolish police and
they want to ban guns well if you get
rid of the cops who takes the guns away
you think a social worker is going to
show up to my house and be like your gun
sir i'm going to be like it's back the
way you came like have a nice day yeah
so how how do you have these people who
advocate for contrary things they're
morons they have no idea what they're
talking about
they're a chaotic destructive force of
tribalists now
to be fair the leftists the actual like
dsa types
they're all pro-gun karl marx has a
quote
that you know uh under no under no
pretext shall the workers
you know give up arms and ammunition or
should arms and ammunition be given up
workers should frustrate this by force
if necessary so the true leftists are
lying never giving up my guns
but the problem is those people fall in
line with joe biden the democrats
because they're easily convinced by the
establishment it's the left
or at least left enough i also don't
think they want us to have guns
that's that's right right they're not
going gonna go fight for us to have a
right to have a gun right
at the end of the day they want them to
have the guns the gravel institute
tweeted that what happened on january 6
was the right thing to do but by the
wrong people
so it shows you everything about what
the left actually believes yeah
or and so there's a difference between
the actual left and the culture war left
and like democrats
it's it's it's hard to quantify this i
know but the dsa people will gladly vote
for democrats
and support warmongering authoritarians
because they're like at least i'm closer
to minimum wage
like oh congratulations that's the
political party
thing bothers me that the people that
have these these ideals would align with
another person that doesn't just because
they both call themselves democrats like
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time